STEPHANIE WONG:
Today, we're talking
about BigQuery Flex
Slots, Kubeflow 1.0,
and taking Next 2020 online.
I'm Stephanie Wong.
And welcome to
This Week in Cloud
where we serve you the
lowest latency news.
BigQuery Reservations
can help you
handle explosive
demand for analytics
without breaking your budget.
Now, BigQuery Flex Slots
take that goal even further,
with a set monthly
cost that is only
billed to you for the seconds
of Flex Slots are deployed.
Use Flex Slots to experiment
with your environment,
plan for big events, or rapidly
respond to unexpected demand.
Kubeflow provides a Kubernetes
native platform for scalable
and portable ML workloads.
And thanks to the support of
its contributor community,
Kubeflow just had its
first major release.
This open source project will
help you develop, build, train,
and deploy your models.
And for enterprise
solutions, consider
using Kubeflow on Google
Cloud's Anthos platform
to run these machine
learning workflows
in hybrid and
multi-cloud environments.
We recently introduced the
Network Intelligence Center,
which offers modules
that can predict and heal
network failures.
One of those modules
is connectivity test,
which helps you diagnose
connectivity issues
and predict the impact
of config changes.
Now, the eng leads for
this product have written
a deep dive on how the
connectivity test module works
and how you can use it
to proactively monitor
your network.
In keeping with
advice from the CDC,
we are reworking Google Cloud
Next into an online experience.
The dates have not changed,
April 6 through the 8,
and any existing
reservations are
being converted to the
new digital connect event.
We're focusing on
innovating how we interact
online with our community.
So stay tuned for
more information
and be sure to
register to join us.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas, leave
us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.